people who have a coherent view of
politics it's one thing is going to lead
to another thing right if you're uh
let's say you're pro-life you know you
don't think that abortion should be
allowed that's going to bleed into your
thoughts on marriage and divorce and
raising children that might even bleed
over into your thoughts on taxes and
education so it's all going to kind of
come together of a piece right
and same thing if you're super liberal
that's they're all those issues are
going to kind of roll off one from the
other but I feel like you could still
find a good middle ground I mean like I
I'm okay with
people owning guns but there's certain
other things I probably wouldn't be okay
with that conservatives are okay okay
like I'm not pro-life yeah not yet
I will not change my mindless that's
what I said but then I got convinced I I
just there's no way I'd be convinced to
change my mind on that yeah no have you
ever thought there's something I'll
never do and then you did it
um I'm sure but like I know for this I
will not change my opinion uh really
quickly show of hands who who here would
date someone who's pro-life
if that guy said I don't want to kill
your child oh I would date the guy I
think there's different things
yeah it's just that that's very
different I think the problem for me I
own my buddy and like I am I I own my
buddies what makes you say you own your
body because I have my buddy and I take
care of it well you are part your body
yeah your body and your part yourself
but you don't own that you didn't know
let me just interrupt you if you believe
that God owns it that it's your belief
but it's not mine but you can't bring
religion into it you cannot bring
religions yeah there's only one universe
and it happens to be true in in that
Universe in my universe it's not true I
have my own set of beliefs and in your
Universe you could pretend to be a bug
with 17 arms but Michael you can't bring
religion into politics well you have to
bring religion I'm no politics I mean
you can like take it into a faster but
you cannot let it set politics no you
have to no because why not so many
different religions it's just like you
can't cater to one being Catholic you
can't cater to just like
that because let me just interrupt you
are not just let me let me just
interrupt really quick and then I'll let
you uh respond so um just one thing
this is a hot button political issue
Michael's conservative I think you guys
probably have a different stance on
abortion I'm happy to talk about it but
I want everyone to try to keep it
people have very strong opinions on this
so I let's hopefully just keep it uh
respectful let's have a debate let's
engage in a uh hopefully a fruitful
debate or not fruitful debate but uh
let's just keep it polite and I I think
um Michael is probably prepared to make
uh pro-life arguments that are not based
in religion
well I think everybody well he was just
making he was just making ultimately
everything because if you're right now
what if I'm not really interested
but that's a problematic aspect why it's
a problem well because because certain
things are true and certain things are
false so like for instance if I said
right now hey is it better to bake a pie
for a widow or kick a little baby in the
head
would you say one of those things is
better than the other thing you can
compare
comparative content but I'm just asking
is wait would you you look at that
situation you have two choices here you
can either bake a pie for old the Widow
down the street or you can kick that
little baby in the head would you say
one of those things is better or worse
than the other one yeah yes yeah so if
you're gonna make a claim that something
is better or worse as a as a moral
question then you are now taking
recourse too because that's a religious
view so how is me making a claim about
like having an abortion and pro-life
obviously I feel like if you're having
an abortion it's not a good thing like I
don't think it's something that should
be romanticized I don't think it's like
a good thing I feel like it's sad that
you even have to go out to that point
but it should be there for women it's
not a good thing then why no one needs
it because there's other things that are
not a good thing birth control is not a
good thing either and we have it but it
we should need it
I'm having sex before marriage is not a
good thing for society but we have it so
you're gonna ban it but you just
shouldn't drugs are not a good thing but
we have it right you also shouldn't do
that you're making very good Arguments
for things there's so many things
I agree with your Viewpoint and I know
you're very passionate about your review
I'm very passionate but I'm I think
we're going a wrong way about the whole
conversation like because you you're
saying that's just wrong but yeah we
have to talk about how can we prevent
that from happening in the first place
like what happens to like a 14 year old
girl who gets raped for example like how
would we prevent that I think we have to
how do you how do you prevent rape well
how do we talk about people with like
mental issues like we have to talk about
just better like are you doing something
to better yeah well the way the way to
prevent rape would be to get tough run
crime and it would be to circumscribe
certain sexual behaviors right and stop
uh I would say probably stop encouraging
a hookup culture that makes a little bit
easier so you can do all sorts of things
like that and then what do you do for
for like a young woman who's already
pregnant what do you do you well you
know the crime has already happened so
if you if she gets an abortion or she
doesn't get abortion that's not going to
change the fact for example you can
maybe like create a foundation that will
help oh yeah there are plenty to like
fund the baby yeah crisis pregnancy
centers they're great great
organizations other accessible to people
yes everywhere well that's good I mean I
don't I don't know like they totally are
okay you tell me where you are I'll get
you an organization so you gave me a
look while I was over there is it what
what's up I was just wondering what
you're doing
I had to go to the bathroom and I got a
nice pack for what neck pain
over here I've got arthritis or
something
um
so you also looked at me Kiko and you
wanted to why don't you and Michael have
a little debate on this
well keep going on oh I think on pretty
much everything no no no what do we
disagree on
I'm pro-choice through and then I'll
never change I will never waver not a
single thing I could be seen
said to me anything I'm not changing my
opinions we might as well not even
debate on it because it doesn't seem
like he's changing his opinion either
but I did change my opinion because I
used to be so you're willing to change
back your opinion well
we believe I am so I know I'm not going
to change no we can then if you want to
debate if you think so in the face of in
the face of compelling evidence I could
change any opinion one thing one thing
really quick me too usually but then
some things you're just setting Stone on
and this is one of those is it maybe
because you're afraid that you'll find
compelling evidence that would convince
you otherwise so one thing really I just
know it's dumb are you guys comfortable
opinion on having this conversation yeah
yeah oh you guys are fine okay yeah okay
yeah oh Beyond comfortable yeah let's
have it
okay because some people don't like
talking about this sort of stuff but
it's so long as you guys are uh fine
having a little debate I think I think
and the the great thing about debate is
is that you can kind of it can help you
reaffirm your position or perhaps
challenge your position I mean I'm
always open to new things things and I
want to keep learning but sure I'm just
saying I'm pretty I agree with Kiko I'm
being very strong on this one yeah so
then what if we have a debate for the
fun of it how's that sound that's what
I'm saying fun okay let's do it fun go
ahead why is this the one issue that you
wouldn't change your mind on
because I feel like the research is
already done we've already taken away
the law put it back we've already seen
the negatives and positives from it so
why are we repeating history we've
already done this multiple times now
what law
when we banned abortion back in what was
in 19
yeah real v Wade Roe v Wade cre created
a constitutional right to abortion yes
but before then before that abortion was
illegal yeah yeah
and then now we saw because the reason
why that happened well there's honestly
multiple reasons why some of it does
stem in racism as well you mean because
most like most black babies in New York
are aborted and not born
that would be racist right
no I mean because the issue was
the reason why we're getting back here
is because
the most people having not the most
majority of the highest percentages of
people having abortions are
African-American women or minority women
in general right the majority of black
babies in New York City are being killed
but the most dangerous place for a black
person in New York city is in his
mother's womb that's very racist
can we all be calling them babies yeah
they're what should I call them fetuses
did you know what the word fetus means
yeah
embryo
is that embryo is another term but the
word fetus is a Latin word that means
Offspring so it means baby isn't like
the um I don't know I think it's in
Freakonomics that they wrote about the
fact that throwing away decreased the
crime rate in New York yeah this was an
argument that was really compelling to
me I actually made this argument to a
bioethicist and who was she was very
proud
I wouldn't say she was the top okay but
I made this argument I said well no I'm
really in favor of abortion because the
Freakonomics book told me that it
decreases the crime rate you know if you
if you abort these babies and she said
cool Michael which of those arguments is
not also an argument for killing young
black men in the inner cities age 18 to
25. and the problem is
they have life well the baby's not alive
they don't feed us but no they have life
no well no no they have life experiences
they have no how are you alive if you
have conscious memories you have no
conscious how are you a living thinking
if you have no conscience should you be
able to kill somebody who's in a coma
who's unconscious honestly yeah if I was
a vegetable why are we having
ventilators who are vegetables for years
no honestly my true opinion yes they
should be dead
at some point because people can be in a
coma for years and then come out of the
coma but you think just kill them anyway
okay honestly if you're going to be on a
ventilator for sick are you vegan are
you vegetarian do you really care that
much about I'm talking about human life
so so are you going to be a foster
behind your conscious we're better than
these things no because because man is
is the only rational animal so man
unlike uh lower animals we have a
rational will so what I'm saying yeah
because we're more rational we have a
high so Consciousness
no but the rational soul is not merely
the uh expression I just feel like you
shouldn't call it I don't really think
you're pro-life maybe you're Pro even
broccoli screams when you pull it from
the ground
I agree no I mean the ultimately the
image because you brought up religion
ultimately the reason is because man is
made of the image and likeness of God
right that's why once again it's
religion for you that's your main
everything ultimately is religious
because that's the fun what if I'm not
religious yeah
everybody's religious because every
every well you just admitted that you
believe some things are better than
other things
so where where does your morality derive
from the Universe I don't need a
religion to tell me what's good or bad
it's just it's Common Sense most of the
time what's good or bad we're not sure
God telling me where does that Common
Sense go like you weren't just you
didn't one I feel like from the time I
was able to have any belief I didn't
need somebody to tell me it's wrong for
me to kill somebody I didn't need
somebody to tell me it's wrong if I
steal this from somebody and I was the
only child too so I didn't need to be
taught that that's just something that
my brain was like it's like a common
sense thing right that's called your
moral conscience and because I didn't
need God to do that it was just me well
you're being a human God gave you your
moral conscience and created
you're listening to me right now I
listened to speak but I wouldn't listen
to anything you do and put it in action
you say abortion is is fine and I say
abortion is bad yes how do you know
which one of us is right how do you know
because humans know nothing really I
think I know something well I know but
really I mean I don't I think the
arguments where life begins is useless
because I don't think I'm based on that
you're not going to change someone
else's mind because everybody has strong
beliefs I think that's a great point
because it doesn't matter when life
begins so much as what life means yeah
so it means so many different things to
people so I just think it's useless to
argue over that I think it's better to
argue how we can what we can do in the
situation because we all agree when life
begins I mean by definition it's a
concept no we don't know
hold on just a second abortion is such a
silly issue women's issues with nature
slash God oh the idea they can escape
consequences and not control every
element of sex is the issue ironically
women side with a eugenesis that created
these schemes and hate them and one than
God
dig Bic energy thank you for the uh 200
TTS yeah thank you there uh interesting
name you have there thank you man um go
ahead Kiko you wanted to well because I
agree with what you're saying but we
said we're debating for fun so that's
the reason why I'm doing it because I
know whatever you said how do I know I'm
right well I mean this is also objective
too but like for me like I know I'm
right because like every state with the
most educated people here like are still
you know pro-choice and like the states
with like you know not that many
educated people usually or the ones that
are
versus if you grab people from
California and you find the most
overall I feel like the the majority
yeah the majority is going to probably
be from California not from I mean
Michael's boosting up the average I
think because it's so small right
because one Yale you throw one Yale in a
Tennessee or
I also don't have a ton of uh you know
respect for people who have all these
credentials I mean my fellow yales
believe all sorts of things that are
insane I mean they don't know the
difference between a man and a woman so
I'm not surprised that they can't tell
what life is about you know also I feel
like I'm just gonna set this from the
straight from the start you and Brian
don't really get a say in this because
you can't have kids oh no uterus no I
have two kids no did you birth them did
they come out of your vagina no no but I
did I did help to make them and the
other even if I didn't have kids the
other reason I would have some say over
this is because I have rational
faculties and I can I can come to
conclusions about things that don't
involve me for instance if I were an
oncologist I wouldn't necessarily need
to have cancer to know something about
it you can have like you can you can
have a say but you're not gonna have the
final say it's not your it's not your
choice it's not your boss why would it
not be I'm the head of my household well
it's so you can just I think what do you
you tell her when and what to do every
move to make you tell like not every
move what you said I've got quite a lot
of over it yeah can I say oh what she's
trying to say is that why do we restrict
women and tell them what to do if we
have to restrict the man because they're
the ones who don't take the
responsibility for what they have done
responsibility you don't know how many
guys invited me over their house on the
first date it is disgusting to say every
time and no but it's it's happening and
I have to like I have to say no but like
we are not educating and saying to the
man that they should behave properly why
we are shaving women for the fact that
they want to have a choice of what to do
with their bodies when the the guys and
the man who they whose attraction
they're trying to get you know like the
women are having sex with their guys
because that's the only way the only
thing they can give guys like right now
be maybe the legacy of value doesn't
that you're so right about that but
doesn't that tell you that those guys
are just dirt bags and you should go but
there are so many of them so what should
I do then yeah
the real problem of abortion and I feel
like abortions are not good they're bad
but I feel like they're needed in some
scenarios I don't think like pro-choice
means all girls should be having sex
like and having abortion unprotected and
just like that should be Plan B is
having an abortion but I feel like there
are instances where like you don't
realize that you're pregnant or just
something goes wrong I feel like it
shouldn't be on like
legal terms it like it's way more about
the situation but you need a law either
it's legal or it's illegal yeah but if
it's legal like that doesn't mean
everyone's gonna get an abortion why do
you think it's bad because I get the
pro-abortion argument which is the
baby's not really a baby it's not life
it's not human forget about it it's just
like I think I think it's bad because
it's a sad thing to go through periods
yeah like it's um why is it sad though
because it's like you have to do
something because I don't think people
really are going in there and being like
I want to kill this fetus like it's not
being like No One's Gonna Be Like I'm
gonna kill this yes it's life no one
still kill life Playmate period but some
for some people it has to happen I know
this girl who's a friend of mine and she
didn't know she was pregnant and she was
on birth control and she found out she
was five months pregnant and she was
like I cannot have this kid like there's
no way I'm in high school this girl
couldn't do it why couldn't she just
have the kid and give him give the kid
up for adoption changes
say that like it's the easiest thing
ever you're talking about abortion like
that's the easiest it's not it's not
yeah but their life changes so much more
after that you know you're having a kid
imagine one at a time one at a time
please otherwise you know you have a kid
in the ground because you killed the kid
because they're not big enough to be
buried they're not gonna they don't know
disintegrated Within
obviously at five months the baby's
pretty so are you pro-life we're at the
five months
I was just like an experience
hold on one microphone at a time I'll
get you after it I was just wondering if
it's like after three months or after no
from the beginning I don't think it you
know I don't think it makes sense to
just pick an arbitrary date and say okay
that's why it's arbitrary though because
it's it's supposed to be by each Case by
case because we can't tell when every
embryo is going to be viable outside
from the beginning that's what but
that's not what about what you think but
what we're saying is why it's Case by
case is because we don't want to say oh
we're gonna ban um after 20 weeks you
can't when some babies might be viable
at age but I don't care when it's so
that's can I finish my statement
go ahead standard that I don't think
Kiko Hugo then Michael then I forgot it
I thought the bathroom though
uh okay um as someone was writing a
message we'll get to it later Michael
did you ever receive yes well just in
yeah in response to that point because
Kiko was focusing on well at what point
is the baby viable to live outside the
mother's room but I that is that isn't
the question that matters the question
that matters is
when is this thing a human when is this
thing alive and the only answer to that
question just by definition is at the
moment of conception because conception
just means the beginning of Life I agree
with you well what it's just sad
scenarios like if a kid is born to like
you know drug addicted parents well they
could give the baby up for adoption but
I really think they're gonna make that
smart choice if they're drug addicted
parents yeah I don't think there's like
enough structure saying any life is
better than the bad life yeah I'm saying
life is better than me I agree with you
all life is better than being killed I
guess another argument is like what if a
girl was young enough right and she's so
desperate that she's gonna go to
somewhere else and or do it herself or
something well you know it's interesting
because you're saying that illegal
abortions would be more dangerous but
they're not actually this is the weird
thing in the year before Roe v Wade was
a loud abortion everywhere do you know
how many women died from illegal back
alley abortions in America
and 24 women died from legal abortion so
you're pro-illegal abortion no I'm
anti-all abortion but when you look at
when you look at the number of states
where it was legal
legal abortions illegal abortions were
roughly
the same thing
do you think like people that uh did it
dangerously like would it be recorded
they would frequently have to well it's
women who die for me
let's have Tatum come out oh no I like
okay if you remember it let me know I
feel like abortions are going to happen
either way like as she was saying like
prostitution it's it's gonna happen
either way and I feel like it's better
if we have a safe way for these women to
get abortions instead of knowing it's
gonna happen and just like putting a
blind eye towards it and but but if
they're if there's a law against it
they're going to be far fewer abortions
I think the law should be more
necessarily
yeah well if there aren't going to be
fewer abortions if you make it illegal
then why not just make it illegal if
it's not going to matter well I think
like for example you know going to a
doctor and like the doctor prescribes
drugs so freely these days like for men
you know it's kind of the same thing
with the boy I think uh if someone's
gonna go get an abortion it should be
much more like the doctor should be part
of the whole yes 100 like try to deter
the person and like for help and how to
deter it yeah yeah I just like making it
so black and white it's just but it just
seems to me you all have I think all of
you have the moral intuition that it's
wrong because because especially because
you're women and you just don't want to
kill your children but so you know that
it's wrong so then why not follow that
to its logical conclusion and say we
shouldn't do it I feel like if it's just
a
little right then when will have less
help with also what she was saying is
this whole situation is not so black and
white it's not just it's wrong there's
like other things that go way into it
that you have to take into part that
make a deciding factor on whether or not
a woman wants an abortion it's not just
like oh I'm doing this thing that's
wrong it's like I'm doing this thing but
I could like there's other parts of it
that's way more wrong too so what do you
what what let's say a girl gets raped do
you really think she wants to have that
reminder of her having a child which she
could give the child up for adoption you
keep saying I would not want to go
through pregnancy you're going through
an entire pregnancy where your whole
body is changing your body's gonna be
changing changed forever but what if you
give birth to someone who is like the
next I don't know
yeah of course the next what or even if
not and that's just a regular person
likely okay what about the next Hitler
and then they're like race but there are
there are about 36 couples who to adopt
for every newborn baby put up for
adoption in the U.S so there would be no
shortage of a couple to adopt the baby
but I know I think it'll be hard to
adopt in the US that's right that's why
because there's so many couples who want
to adopt every newborn baby
expensive yeah so either way it's
changing that girl's life forever the
girl's life's already changed she's
crazy
it's different because when you see it
becomes real when you don't see it it's
not real it doesn't well when you don't
see it it doesn't see no I've known
people that had abort
ion how would you even know as a man if
it's gonna be a detrimental change to
This Woman's life how would you well
because I you don't know I have children
and I know women carrying a child I know
plenty of women who've had babies and I
know plenty of women who've had
abortions and I have seen that I do too
much no and I know and you're telling me
that abortions have not affected if my
mom hadn't had the abortion she had I
wouldn't be here your mother had
abortion
part of the reason
you defy your mother's abortions
I was pro-choice before that before your
mother before she I found out
you were obviously raised in an
environment that's pro-abortion so you
know certainly your views are going to
be colored no no my dad's not pro
abortion my mom's not pro-abortion and
I'm so pro-abortion there's like certain
I don't think like we said there's
middle grounds on things that we take
but no this this is not a middle ground
you're just saying I'm pro-abortion I
think a lot of them
yeah the government telling them I think
a lot of a lot of it with women is that
they don't like the fact that it's the
government that's dictating it but the
government dictates all these important
I know but I think it's just and I don't
like dictate you don't like that there
are laws against burglary and like no
they don't try to dictate like my body
and trying to tell me what to do with it
do you think there should be laws
against heroin like using heroin
that's a law against against you using
your body as you like
so people still do heroin right but far
fewer people do but that's detrimental
to your body that's like a drug that's
gonna ruin you having an abortion is
Gonna Save A Lot of women's life no save
a lot of women's lives oh it doesn't it
doesn't it there is no condition in
which a woman needs an abortion so how
does it ruin your child if that child
has no consciousness never existed never
started
a memory yeah never had her birthday
like most time never even had
anything yeah like how how is that
ruining someone's life that never
because the child is deprived of the
chance to grow up I don't think we can I
don't think the child cares about it
when I never even yeah but a person can
be deprived of something without being
conscious of it like in the case of
killing someone in a coma so so like
right now I'm being deprived of being
a billionaire so my life is no because
because you're you're not entitled to be
a billionaire you don't have a right
you're not you're not entitled really to
life either you do if in fact if you
have any rights at all you must
necessarily they thought our Health Care
system and everything that's going on
technically you don't have entitlement
to life because the simple things we
need to live is so expensive that most
people can't even afford it here so how
is that an entitlement to life we're all
living just fine
with the whole population you think
we're all living just fine yeah I think
we're living
how do you define consciousness like
what is consciousness when you have like
do we know what Consciousness I would
say you're conscious
and once like because some people
believe that because I don't use this
exists in the universe right yeah that's
a hormone we think I don't really
because I don't want from my thing I
don't say oh it's wrong once they're
conscious my whole thing is once they're
viable on their own and I'm not talking
about because if they they are they are
a parasite at that point I'm not saying
like they are viable in the point like
they have to be born and like can just
walking be on their own but if they are
born and can't be on a ventilator or
something and a machine can't even keep
them alive yeah they they are just a
parasite at that point I mean they're a
creature living in our body if it had a
different name we would have killed it
and gotten rid of it just like if it was
a pregnancy that was killing our body we
would get rid of it because right now
it's a parasite that's hurting the body
the difference between a parasite though
and what you're describing is that what
you're describing is your child it's
human it's not a parasite it's a human
being is it really though at that point
yeah yeah I don't know that's where we
disagree no well it's not just a matter
of disagreement DNA and for you are you
um it doesn't though
yes I'm very proud so how are you saying
that everyone has a right to live if
you're death penalty well because the
Civil Authority the Civil Authority has
the right to exactly you're doing the I
I wrote a whole topic on in debate class
because if you're religious right yeah
so how are you pro-death penalty if you
are not good because the because uh
whosoever sheds the blood of Man by man
shall his blood be shed because man is
made in the image and likeness of God
but who is who is to decide when to take
that this civil Authority which does not
bear The Sword in vain but who is the
who is to decide who that civil
Authority is well there are different
forms of civil Authority there's
monarchy oligarchy and democracy and
differences at different times well no
God does in his forward and in
Providence uh uh permits civil Authority
and it entrusts the enactment of Justice
to that Civilization but you said that
my body belongs to the God
your body belongs to God as does your
soul I feel like
I feel like there's really no argument
because well here's why I mean I'll just
do it like really quickly as to why
religion has to come into it is because
all of our political ideas rest on as we
have discussed ideas of Applied morality
right what's good and what's bad and
morality rests on the basis of
epistemology which is how we can know
anything at all and epistemology rests
on a basis of anthropology which is the
question of what is human nature what is
a human even to know anything and
anthropology rests on a basis of
ontology which is what does it mean to
be and then ontology rests on a basis of
theology which is what is the fundament
of reality the the the uh okay so you're
saying it all goes back to religion but
I'm saying you can't go back to one
religion because there's multiple
religion is a habit of of justice that
renders to God what he is due that's
what that means yeah we don't even
understand what that I think we're all
living a video game yeah
it might be a decent metaphor so I have
a question for you Michael um if you had
to to steal man the uh pro-choice side
yeah you familiar with I assume you're
familiar with the term steel man
um what what are some of the what is or
what are some of the strongest arguments
that you hear from people who are
pro-choice the strongest argument for
abortion would be that
there's no such thing as God I guess the
strike because in order for abortion to
be
even remotely acceptable
there would we would just have to be
stuff we just have to be matter right
there wouldn't be good or bad or right
or wrong
metaphysics were also a soul yeah but I
believe in physics more than metaphysics
well the two go together but then the
way they can coexist together if you're
saying they're different no different
things we're we're all different people
and yet we co-exist together
but then you're saying that we have like
so you know
I should not believe in God for me to
not believe in pro-life
well I mean there are I could make
plenty of secular Arguments for anything
you want it's just ultimately ultimately
it does come down to God because
everything comes down to God ultimately
so what would be if if we remove
religion if we remove religion from it
what what is the strongest argument you
hear from someone who's pro-choice is it
a bodily autonomy argument or is that
not particularly compelling I mean I
think they're all really pretty silly
arguments the strongest argument I could
imagine is that is that we live in a
materialist world so all of the
metaphysical things that we pretend to
care about or we think that we care
about you know our loves our hopes our
dreams our Joys our emotions that's all
just fake it's all a trick played by
chemicals firing off in our brains and
we're actually just bags of Flesh and
we're eventually going to die and take a
dirt nap and turn to worm food and
that's all that there is just Oblivion
which which can be uh compelling in the
modern world yeah no I mean and that's
how we that's very often how we treat
ourselves though
actually the way that we behave the way
that you're all talking you don't really
believe that because you're saying
something well you don't want to believe
that because you don't want to believe
that because people do want to believe
that because they want to live without
conscience I feel like if we all
believed that we had all lived a very
sad and like mopey life and like not
really caring about anything and I feel
like people want to believe that so they
have reason and purpose and something
for them to do with their life and so
that they're just not on
themselves all day long no well what you
would if I didn't believe in God
which I didn't for a while I would do
what I did then which is just be very
hedonistic I would party all the time I
would you disagree I don't believe in
God but I'm not hedonistic why not
because I don't care for me the
short-term pleasure doesn't have any uh
um like any good in it I pursue
long-term pleasure I pursue long term
um achievements goals
um ideas and I know a lot of people who
are religious who do are do want
short-term pleasure very well yeah it's
called sin and Temptation that's true
but but you know so you're interested in
long-term goals yeah but why because in
the grand scheme of things in the grand
scheme of things that's still short term
but by the perspective of Eternity right
the scientists
my life my life that's what long-term is
but that's a blip that's nothing I care
as long as like I can think my
Consciousness is here that's what I care
about I don't care what's going to be
like there after whatever and what's
been before me what matters right now is
like what my conscience can take and my
conscience can only take what is
happening right now right here it cannot
take the yesterday anymore it cannot
take the future anymore you can only
take right now and right now I believe
that
I'm right now I'm pursuing my my you
know live dreams that are not
um necessarily
um like short-term pleasure like I'm not
like I don't know I'm I'm going for
Masters let's say it's not something
very appealing like it's not that I'm
gonna go through a party after the show
but like it's still um it has more value
to me than something hedonistic as you
were saying
that's good it's I'm I'm stumped because
it's good that you're doing that I just
don't think it makes sense that you're
doing that if there's nothing higher
well because
yeah I think you're just kind of being
happy like yeah that's right for
yourself does that be a greater being
because so because you're suppressing
your own short-term happiness for
long-term happiness I'm just impressing
my insurance you just said that you were
no you're giving up short-term Pleasures
for a long time for me party is not fun
I don't derive fun in that I don't know
I'm not giving up short-term pleasure
yeah different Pleasures yeah okay okay
that makes sense
did you have a final thought on this I
have one more question for you Michael
related to this and then we'll move on
to a different topic oh I mean one thing
he said was if I even remember my full
point but you started saying like the
only argument against
um pro-life is like there's no God or
whatever and I just think
yeah maybe that's what
you know highly Catholic people think
but I feel like for most pro-choice
people is we just put
higher
higher importance over the living woman
over the embryo inside we put we put
more importance over present the present
woman who's living who has her life
already established and what can change
and giving her the choice because only
that woman knows how that
whatever is inside of her will affect
her so it's giving her that choice
instead of forcing her to have
something that has no establishment that
nobody's gonna miss except for maybe her
the only one who's gonna feel the most
pain is the person having the abortion
yeah
it depends also physically it would
depend on when you had the abortion but
but the the reason that I don't find
that very compelling is because I agree
you're right that's what the modern kind
of liberal Pro abortion people say but
it doesn't make sense even by the
liberal premises because the the idea of
modern liberalism is that you have
certain rights and we call these human
rights we call them natural rights and
so the basic ones that our country is
sort of founded on is life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness but the problem
with that is the you're saying that you
would prioritize the Liberty in a
certain sense of the mother of pursuit
of happiness because her happiness is
going to be so almost over the life of
the family it's her life it's her
Liberty and it's her Pursuit it's
already in America because I can see
that thing is not even we don't even
know where that thing is going to be
born it could be born anywhere is that
that's life Liberty
University it could be born in any
country any
Life's a mystery isn't it but but the
reason that's not compelling is because
you're saying that these these secondary
rights like liberty and the pursuit of
happiness and I don't know fajitas on
Saturday that these these are all Trump
the fetuses the baby's right to life but
that can't be the case because those
other rights rely upon the right to life
that the right to life is not one right
among many but it's the basic
fundamental right without which none of
the others can exist
Tatum you wanted to go go ahead you had
something I just feel like abortion
should not be based off of like
like you're saying it was like it's not
liberal ideology and stuff that like
yeah I'm not a liberal either so I I
don't really care you know I just feel
like it's more about experience like the
personal experience the concept you're
going through context you can't do a
house to generalization and call it an a
sound argument but do you you don't you
don't make your moral decisions just
based on how you're feeling in the
morning you don't think that would be a
sound wave yeah decisions abortions are
thought through yeah but yeah so that's
different than what you just said though
which is it can't be just this rigid you
know ideological thinking it's got to be
more based on what you're feeling no it
can't be so black and white yeah there's
way more put into it it's not situation
good and bad thing it's there's a lot I
think the only black and white is we
probably shouldn't talk about abortion
and death penalty in the same sentence
why not I don't see there any
contradiction I agree with you it's just
that you know I agree with you like
death penalty is just you know people
already to be sentenced to that people
committed well apparently everyone has
their rights
you know there was a case where it was
wrongfully you know someone was
wrongfully accused oh yeah so it's just
yeah I mean um so that's why like I
don't know but that doesn't mean we get
rid of the Criminal Justice System no I
totally agree with you it's just like
you know a child is innocent and then
you talk about death penalty not you I
just yeah no of course well that's true
if you sentence a guy to 50 years in
prison you know that's a shame too small
that we talked about like an innocent
child and then
I just bring up the death penalty
because you're over here talking about
how everyone has the right to life but
now you're dictating whether or not
someone can have life no I'm saying that
the Civil Authority has the right and
the responsibility to enact Justice not
God anymore apparently yeah well the
Civil Authority governs the Affairs on
Earth but then you're saying God has and
like decides all of that so why didn't
the god decide that I don't know
Vladimir Putin is not the best person on
the planet and okay it's a fallen world
and sin and death pervade the world
because Adam ate it so how can I then
trust somebody and trust that somebody
will make a decision if that decision is
inconclusive and different uh like I'd
address the Civil Authority yeah even
it's already Oregon like how do you if
it's so the only person that can can
have a trust in his only myself and my
own moral whatever that is yourself have
you made mistakes are you a perfect
person not even close you can't trust
yourself so why do we trust you why do
we trust the Civil Authority why do we
trust them if we can't trust ourselves
well because people I mean I'm not
necessarily telling you to trust me
though I like to think that I've in some
way so why do we trust the silver
because people practice varying degrees
of virtue advice both of which are
habits and so the more you practice them
the easier they become though it's a
Fallen World so we all still make
mistakes and so what we want is to in
this country elect leaders who are
virtuous and who are wise and who are
prudent and just like you I just want to
ask I thought you were volunteering to
be a leader no but um based on all your
beliefs yeah I'm curious so we're moving
towards the future where artificial
intelligence is going to be so prevalent
right oh this is where well this is kind
of where I think I was going Tatum did
you have something really quick that you
wanted to say okay by the way guys
there's 8 000 people watching right now
drop a like and uh you know the chat is
on fire oh my God you guys are crazy
wait how many how many views do you
usually get like live
uh we well it's been steadily going up
but normally we get like two or three
thousand concurrents so we've almost
like we've tripled
so we brought up abortion they're all up
here it could be that it could be in any
case um so you're about to talk about uh
artificial intelligence were you gonna
bring up artificial wombs is that where
you were going yeah like the EXO one but
I was gonna ask ask you first and I
would love to cover that topic as well
but so since we're moving towards that
and at some point I'm sure there's going
to be not even some sum of government
but this the social justice system
that's based on AI that AI is going to
scan things and
um So based on maybe hold on just a
second underscore one two five seven
eight dab d241 wow greasy donated
one dollars
equal rights key the workforce twice the
workers and cut income in half basic
supply and demand core funding abortion
get their workers back for any money
instead of costing maternity leave
avoiding pregnancy leaves you serving
Masters that hate and let you
um it's just true so true great Point
yeah uh so
just because we're we don't have a ton
of time to continue on this specific
subject I do want to move it on just and
you know with the whole artificial
intelligence thing
um Michael what do you think about this
as perhaps a potential middle ground or
compromise between the pro-life and the
pro-choice side and obviously this could
be decades or even centuries in the
future
um the development of an artificial womb
what if we saw both sides come together
and say hey we're going to put all our
lobbying money all our Outreach money
basically all the money that's thrown at
this issue from both sides and say we're
gonna have a joint research fund where
we're going to research an artificial
womb that way a woman could uh if she
was so inclined she could end the
pregnancy however the life could
continue in an artificial womb do you
think that that could be a potential
compromise it's a bit of a futurist
you're saying an artificial womb to be
used in the case that a woman tries to
have an abortion you say okay you're
going to be funneled into this
artificial womb are you saying for
everybody
well if if a woman a woman could still
have a normal pregnancy through with it
of course but uh in the event that for
example she wanted to terminate the
pregnancy
um
just in the same way how it is if it
were a sort of medical device to save a
baby I guess I'd be for it but already
there but it's still babies yeah well
they're all sorts of it's a concept but
it's basically going to be in the future
but the fear is that women just start
using it and that would be very bad
because it would establish the
domination of Technology over the origin
and Destiny which is super creepy what
about in vitro and Echo they're very bad
no no bueno
that's not good it's not good because
maybe for everybody because a baby has a
right to uh be born and to be conceived
through the conjugal activist parents
who are joined together in perpetuity in
the in in matrimony and furthermore
there's a danger with something like IVF
or all the rest of it of establishing
the dominance of either the state or big
business maybe even worse or technology
broadly over as I previously had said
the origin and Destiny of human life
which is super creepy do you think that
I even like Elon Musk it's a losing
battle I feel like because it's moving
towards that anyway like we're moving so
much so we can stop things I mean we you
know the the atomic bomb was invented
what 70 80 years ago and we everybody
thought that that was going to lead to
constant atomic war going to blow the
world up we've only seen the bombs used
twice well because it doesn't it doesn't
really benefit Humanity this would
benefit I mean people would feel like it
would benefit their life so the atomic
bomb benefits belligerence yeah but come
on nobody wants to like blow something
like blow the planet of it people know
that there are people who want that yeah
yeah they'll know that it would end all
life so if there's a artificial womb a
lot of people would feel the benefit so
I feel like
um a large percentage of the world would
push towards that so it would win out
there are all sorts of I mean one
tactical nuclear weapons would not
destroy the world but let's hope but but
there are plenty of scientific
advancements that we curtail we could
clone people I I think pretty simply
it's not successful yeah well it's it's
illegal in most places
it's been for a long time like for 20
years already so nothing but we don't do
it because it raises but okay so what
about the issue like for example you
know the whole genetic testing and then
how you can edit genes yeah very bad
well very bad but what if you can edit
out like a really crippling disease how
would you feel about that yeah well if
you're talking about treatments in the
womb I could see a strong argument for
that you have a little you have
surgeries in the womb things like that
if you're talking about rewriting the
code of life that seems one to use a
very modern term very ableist you know
that you're trying to write out I like
crispr technology has been already
around for so long like I know it's not
morally yet accepted but right if we
keep going into that direction because
what's the problem with it morally I
agree I feel like that's a very bad
enhancement for society I feel like it
would be taken advantage of I feel like
people would use it the wrong way and I
I don't think that's good that we're
changing people's genetic code but you
can also change it to prevent cancer and
all of the bad diseases yeah but what
difference does it mean exactly the
thing about like you're playing God like
you're like you're you're like you're
saying that so the person should die
from cancer then so no more
technological advances
right and this is wrong and treat things
differently and say you are The God Who
because you decide what is good and bad
but I'm when you get when you have that
when people have that power and control
in their hands it can be taken the total
wrong way and it's going to start
getting capitalized off of people and be
like oh well now we can make us look
better and cooler and like there's this
and you can do that and it's just you
get it it's just gonna go down the wrong
way